and welcome to sofa Ridge on Sunday now
when it comes to brexit there's a lot
that divides but the one thing that
seems to unite is that everyone would
rather delay than make a decision
whether it's the government MPs and now
the European Union who this week agreed
to delay brexit until the end of October
with the pressure easing off MPs have
headed home for Easter and we can turn
our attention to other things such as
what to do with the WikiLeaks founder
Julian Assange we will be talking about
that a little later in the program with
his lawyer
Jennifer Robinson but don't worry we'll
still get our regular bricks that fix
with guests including in Duncan Smith
and Anna Sabri coming up now the break
that delay means that the UK will
probably take part in European elections
elections that could see a breakthrough
for some of Britain's at Newark
political parties one of those is change
UK or the independent group and their
brexit spokesperson and a Subaru will be
on the program very shortly to speak
with her now what we can do is show you
a little bit of the challenge that the
new parties face when it comes to those
European elections we can have a quick
look at some of the latest polling when
it comes to how people are intending to
vote when it comes to the EU Parliament
elections you can see there at labour
topping the polls they're on 24% this is
according to you Goff polling done on
the 10th and 11th of April and second
place it is the Conservatives on 16% and
then the brexit party that's Nigel
Frazier's new party on 15 percent
followed by you kept on 14% the Lib Dems
on 8 the Greens on 8 and change UK on 7%
let's talk about some of those findings
with Anna suberin who joins us now in
the studio thank you very much for being
with us this morning pleasure but it's
not you've been up even longer anyway
God well anyway what is this slightly
less good news is the polling for change
UK when it comes to the European
election and 7% are you bit disappointed
well just two things first of all of
course we're not even a political path
so for change UK already to resonate
with people especially as I think a lot
of people know us as take and so I think
that was my second point was that I
think we're known more as the Tiggers
then change UK so I'd like to see some
polling with tick because when when we
sort of launched or whether we came
together I cell polling was amazing when
you're up to something like 11 12
percent it's a bit hard to keep the
momentum going no not really I mean look
the whole of brexit the brexit thing of
course dominates everything and of
course certain parts of brexit are going
to be absolutely the headline story in'
understandably but i think there's a
solid consistency there for us and as i
said we're not even a party and I think
that as hopefully we form a political
party which is obviously our intention
and we will field candidates across the
whole of Break Britain I think be
including at the local elections as well
know far too late for local elections
far far far too late the nominations
closed about two three weeks two weeks
ago but in any event we're not in a
position to be able to do that but the
European Parliament elections are you
bet and I think that it'll be a real
opportunity for be able to get to know
more about it then a lot of people
already know a lot about us they know
that we believe in that second
referendum at people's vote so we want
that revote I think people know that we
want to us to remain in the European
Union the best deal that our country has
and of course we're a party of change of
reform not just in the UK but across the
way that we do politics in the European
Union as well and we've got to be part
if we're successful of that reform that
needs to take place in the European
Union when you look at the polling and
you see kind of still kind of muddling
along with you know the Lib Dems the
Green Party do you think that actually
strategically in the long term you're
gonna have to start to doing a few more
alliances working together with other
parties like the Lib Dems but we do
anyway I mean this although the
beginning you were very clear and saying
that you're not going to be associated
with them no no we we are a political we
will be hopefully a political party in
our own right and we very much want
people to come and join us to give their
support to us and be part of change UK
be part of the independent group
and in terms of working together in
Parliament that's been one of the
features of brexit he's that and that's
actually what brought people like me in
sugar and moon and Chris Leslie and
others together was our work on brexit
I'll work for a people's vote our
concerns about the future of our country
and we already work with the Lib Dems
with pride coming with green with
Caroline Lucas with the SNP in any event
or brexit but very much hope people will
come and join us because we need that
change in British politics and I think
that includes all the political parties
not just the main two political party
Nigel francese brexit party unveiled
quite a high profile supporter this week
in the sister of Jacob Riis market ELC
Brock Stowe but I just don't think you
know most people have give if you've got
anyone up your sleeve that it's going to
be joined joining you what you hope will
be a political party anyway all I can
say is genuinely I well we are
overwhelmed by the number of people
who've applied to stand as a member of
change UK anyone we might have heard of
I can't I mean I'd love to but I can't
because actually would be breaching
their confidence because we're going
through what he's going to is a huge
selection procedure but I mean we are
talking about people of from all
backgrounds right across the country
from people who've never been involved
in politics before but have joined us
because of their concerns about brexit
and their support for a people's vote
and they know that the best deal we have
is the current deal with the EU right
the way through to some names that I
went my goodness me he or she wants to
stand for you come on such a tackle and
actually genuinely would be a breach of
their confidence but if they if some of
those people are successful then they
can be sure you'll know who they are but
a genuinely it's amazing okay well we'll
have to wait we'll have to wait to see
to see if we will think it's a
nominations closed tomorrow morning at
10 o'clock but you can only this is
really important I mean obviously people
do have a passion for remaining in the
European Union a lot of people and a lot
of donation for leaving as well yeah but
it's changing Sophie I mean I was out in
Nottingham you
today as I often do with the people's
vote and what's really striking is that
people are beginning to change their
mind do you think that's right because
yeah methinks actually people becoming
more entrenched in their positions
whether it's on the remain side you know
wanting to revoke wanting to stay in all
the leaves though people saying actually
no I want to live with leave with no
dear I don't disagree with you you're
right that there's an entrenchment at
those edges but what's really striking
are those people either remain as who
said no except the referendum isn't we
don't want another revote on it they're
changing their minds but destroy King
Lee older people and I I'm at a number
yesterday and not him he said you know
what I voted leave and they told me why
and then they said I've changed my mind
wonder people's vote because I've
listened to my children and my
grandchildren and it's about their
future and whichever way you cut breaks
it we're going to be damaging their
future so there is a movement and
actually that's why I hope we do get
that people's about confirming revote
call it what you will call it second
referendum call it what you want we all
know what it means
and it's that chance for people to
change their minds now they know what
backs it looks like and also for young
people who bear the brunt of wrecks it
to have their say in their voice but
people want BME peace but they've got to
realize it's a proper full-time
commitment if you get elected because
they could be there for five years
they could be there for five weeks five
months who knows what I've got it's a
couple of months now
since you left the Conservative Party
are you feeling any kind of pangs of
regret or missing it a bit I have to say
and I have never felt so sure about
anything and almost every day especially
when I sit in Parliament and I look at
the benches opposite of course it's an
entirely different view and you know
frankly I listen to people like Marc
Francois who is now seen as being the
voice of conservatism Jacob Riis mob
Boris Johnson and the rest of them
afraid the Tory party is the brexit
party and One Nation Tories like me they
can't stay and it's moving to the right
and if someone like Boris Johnson or
Dominic Raab becomes the next leader the
next Prime Minister will it will
absolutely be that real understanding
that it's gone to the towards the more
extremes of the right because
spoken to you know a lot of concepts for
the last couple of months about the
tickets if you like and a lot of them
say look Sarah Williston Heidi Allen
they were never real conservatives but
Anna sue she was a proper Tory don't you
feel that I'm I'm me and my values I
mean this might be sad but my values and
my principles are pretty much not
changed over 40 years oh yes hugely
absolutely huge yeah I mean look at it
now and look at it how it was in 2010 15
so in that government I served in 2010
to 2015 we were in we were in a
coalition with the Lib Dems now the
Conservative Party is in hock to the DUP
I think that says everything about the
shift but can I just say about Heidi and
Sarah it's actually quite a times not
for me to speak and a half but actually
Heidi and Sarah who were people who've
done other things before what like me
before they came into Parliament but you
know Sarah in particular we know was
selected in that open primary Heidi who
read astrophysics whose run a family
business with bucket loads to offer and
was embraced by the Conservative Party
if if the Tories can't win and keep hold
of people like that then they've
absolutely lost that centre ground and
that's our point they've gone they've
this is a party that's changed not us as
individuals and as people like me have
worked with people like Chuck oh and
Chris Leslie and Luciana burger over
brexit in particular that's I find my
values my principles I feel much more at
home with people like Chaka and Chris
and Luciana and the others then I have
felt in the Tory party especially since
2016 when Theresa May got elected as
prime minister and she made that
terrible speech in my opinion talking
about citizens of the world as citizens
of nowhere the u.s. is missing the
remain as as liberal metropolitan elite
which was a nonsense and then calling EU
citizens queue jumpers okay this is the
party that's changed not me